her mother report has been finished for
about four months
and a matter of public record for almost
four years it seems it found no evidence
the Trump colluded with Russia in 2016
but don't let that get in the way which
is why he's still president now but
don't let that get in the way but
Hollywood can't accept it and that never
gets out of the way so they're
constructing a new alternative universe
to live in and here we go it's a new
video for billionaire Tom stires
pro-impeachment group several
celebrities in a few different states
are pretending to audition for a role in
an upcoming molar report movie that's
never going to happen
watch president Stevens I need oil tea I
expect loyalty loyalty I expect loyalty
what that's the real Muller report work
forward yeah come on
the president told the FBI director that
he needed loyalty yeah yeah Michael
Loftus is a comedian and he created the
mag a comedy tour which is traveling all
around the country Michael what's going
on with your people these are the
Hollywood people that you hang out with
they've lost their minds they've lost
their minds you're witnessing what the
left does best they do two good things
right one is organized fiction two is
waste money so so that this is actually
both we have here we've got Debra
Messing pretending she's never heard of
the Mulla report she's like them this is
the Muller report what in the Sam Hill
come on honey
she tweets more than the president she
tweets like she has stock in Twitter
well so they thought about her aegis so
they thought the mullah report was
finally gonna free them from Donald
Trump it's out it didn't he's gonna come
to town on the 17th so in a couple of
weeks so we'll have another page another
chapter but why do maybe you could
explain this to me I don't know the
answer John Lithgow and others were
auditioning in New York they're doing
this fake audition la what are they
planning on accomplishing is this
therapy we're witnessing III think we're
watching them that they're trying to get
every
little piece of emotion out of this they
want to continue to scare America that's
what it's all about
it's a it's a fake audition for a fake
movie based on a report that was based
on a fake dossier it's the fake trifecta
so all they can try to do is scare
people and lift Gao did his best I saw
lift cowboy he was putting a spin on it
the line was like answer the phone and
lift cows like I'm sure the phone like
it was third Rock from the Sun right it
was outrageous I want to do my own
version of this I want to do dramatic
readings of like the Clinton impeachment
testimony that would be great you could
get like Arnold Schwarzenegger to be the
president you know I did not have sex
with relations with that woman I didn't
to do it yeah you got to believe me
right so Michael you would be great you
would not do that I know you're kidding
because you have this thing called a
life a career and a family you will not
be that obsessed with somebody you have
never met but you came out and you had
the courage to come out and I give you
credit for that you told the world that
you voted for Donald Trump how would
your life change since thankfully of my
circle of friends there they're good
people even my liberal friends they
haven't totally freaked out it's the
weirdos from like high school in college
on Facebook who are like they're just in
shock I tell you what people who are
anti Trump are just getting they're
getting like a free gym membership they
watch these these programs and their
heart rate goes up so but so fast it's
like they they're getting a workout I
have to tell you if you're relaxed I
don't want to bring business into the
world of acting and arts but there's
more movies being done there's more
investment happening there's more
opportunities because its economy is
thriving you might not want to give them
credit but you're not might not want to
turn the page in a year because we know
what we left and we know it could be
straight ahead Michael I'm gonna watch
you on tour follow you around like some
type of crazy fanboy as you go on your
maggot or congratulations and thanks for
being here and almost dressing up for me
Michael Loftus thanks